well late news now of course is your
local election headquarters and lawyers
for republican congressional candidate
dan rodimer
successfully got a judge thrown off
their case for a new election just hours
before nevada certifies its results
the secretary of state a republican will
present those results to the state
supreme court tomorrow for certification
now rodimer
is suing clark county for a new election
citing issues with the county signature
verification system now this is the race
we're talking about the third
congressional district
congresswoman susie lee won re-election
by more than 12 000 votes as you see
there
but rhodamer's lawyer says the county
sent ballots to tens of thousands of
addresses where voters no longer live
among some other claims
well this morning they filed a motion
for judge gloria sturman to recuse
herself
citing her work with an organization
that according to its website
tries to get democratic women elected to
congress
although i live in this particular
congressional district
i don't really i don't i think i may
have met miss lee
but i don't know her i live on the same
street as mr rodin
i understand it but the reality is is
the question is is
is the appearance of bias uh there you
know
i'm mr rodimer's neighbor wouldn't that
be an appearance of bias
a little bit of court for you there
ethics rules allow for judges to align
themselves with political parties
but as you know all judicial elections
here in nevada are nonpartisan
emerge nevada responding to all this
saying in a statement judge sturman is
an alum of the program and they also say
there is no conflict
they say rodimer is trying to discredit
her judge sturman did throw out an
almost identical lawsuit friday
involving
losing congressional candidate jim
marchand she cited several issues in
that case including a lack of concrete
evidence now a new judge
will take over this rhodemer case denis